mitten im grünen in sachsen-anhalt die
diese brandneue fabrikhalle die stadt
sandersdorf-brehna hat hier mit
steuergeldern eine produktionsstätte für
solaranlagen hochgezogen kosten satte 83
millionen euro
doch jetzt hat die kleinstadt ein ganz
ganz großes problem der nutzer der halle
die firma vetro solar gmbh ist gleite
und die kommune hat eine teure und
nutzlose solar produktionshalle an der
backe
üblicherweise ist es in deutschland ja
so dass sich firmen ihre fabriken selbst
bauen
die vetro solar gmbh hatte da mehr glück
sandersdorf brehna nimmt einen millionen
kredit auf und baut dem unternehmen
diese eindrucksvolle haller der plan in
jährlichen raten an die stadt sollte die
firma die baukosten zurückzahlen aber
aus diesen hochfliegenden städtischen
visionen wird nichts denn schon kurz
nach baubeginn geht es mit dem solar
valley steil bergab vetro solar gerät in
turbulenzen und stillt ende märz den
betrieb ein
aber warum ging die stadt dieses
wirtschaftliche risiko ein und stellt
einer firma einfach so eine fabrikhalle
hin
gerne hätten wir uns das vom
bürgermeister erklären lassen
aber der will nicht mit uns sprechen und
schon gar kein interview geben
schriftlich heißt es lediglich dass
derzeit umfangreiche bemühungen
bezüglich der vermarktung der
produktionshalle und der grundstücke
laufen zumindest mit ihm auf dem dach
erzeugten strom wird derzeit geld
verdient sagt die stadt
aber das kann den volkszorn in
sandersdorf brehna nicht beruhigen
da müssten zur verantwortung ziehen die
das hier nämlich dann die die gelder zur
bereitgestellten die müssten auf die
finger klopfen
was sagen jetzt daraus werden das geld
ist verschwendetes rausgeschmissen weil
sich das sparen können das war absehbar
dass die zeit kommt wo die ganzen form
wie ich schon sagte wieder bankrott
gehen
in der städtischen solar halle regiert
nun der insolvenzverwalter alles wird
ausgeräumt die restlichen anlagen
abgebaut und dabei hat die stadt ihrem
einstigen prestige-objekt doch eine so
hübsche positive adresse gegeben
auf der sonnenseite nummer eins geholfen
hat es wenig